MR. MILIBAND, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IRC LISTS.
WE NEED TO SPEAK ABOUT UKRAINE.
UKRAINE IS ON YOUR LIST.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN GO ON THERE IN
THE LAST FEW WEEKS, CERTAINLY
LOOKS TO CATASTROPHIC ON
SEQUENTIALLY IS, AND NOT JUST
FOR UKRAINE.
OBVIOUSLY, ALL OF EUROPE IS AT
RISK.
HOW CAN UKRAINE POSSIBLY COPE
WITH WHAT IS GOING ON NOW?
>> I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT ARE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THE RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS IN UKRAINE THAT
YOU'VE BEEN COVERING.
FIRST OF ALL, THE PUMMELING OF
THE CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE
SPEAKS TO A WIDER TREND IN
GLOBAL AFFAIRS.
CONFLICT IS INCREASINGLY
FOCUSED ON HITTING CIVILIANS
RATHER THAN HITTING SOLDIERS.
THE MAJORITY OF VICTIMS AND WAR
ARE NOW CIVILIANS.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE INCREASINGLY
URBAN NATURE OF WARFARE, ALSO
TO THE TACTICS THAT ARE BEING
USED BY VARIOUS PARTIES TO
CONFLICTS.
AND THIS CASE, THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY STRATEGY DOES SEEM TO
BE TO HEAD THE CIVILIAN
POPULATION, AND TRY TO EXERT
PAIN THAT WAY, HAVEN'T BEEN
PUSHED BACK ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
IT THINK IT'S WORTH POINTING
OUT THAT'S THE LAST I SAW, 80
90% OF THE MISSILES THAT ARE
COMING INTO UKRAINE ARE BEING
INTERCEPTED.
THAT STILL LEADS THE CIVILIAN
POPULATION EXTREMELY VULNERABLE,
BOTH TO THE DIRECT YET, AND
SECONDLY, OBVIOUSLY, TO THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE SITUATION
WHERE THERE IS MINUS, FIVE
MINUS TEN DEGREES CENTIGRADE.
THEY HIT THE POWER SECTOR IS
VERY DANGEROUS.
THAT LEADS TO THE SECOND POINT,
WHICH, IS AS YOU HUNTED, THIS
IS A REGIONAL CRISIS, A GLOBAL
CRISIS, NOT JUST UKRAINE
CRISIS.
CERTAINLY REFUGEES ACROSS
BORDERS AND TO EUROPE, THEY'RE
HANDLING THAT WITH A REAL
DETERMINATION, BUT OBVIOUSLY,
THERE'S A FEAR THAT IF THE
RUSSIAN BOMBARDMENT IS
SUCCESSFUL, THERE WILL BE MANY
MORE REFUGEES CREATING MORE
PRESSURE INSIDE OF EUROPE.
>> AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT
PRESSURE, HOW WORRIED ARE YOU
THAT THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY
DESTABILIZE EUROPEAN UNITY.
AS YOU KNOW, ALREADY A
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE.
>> I'M ACTUALLY STRUCK THE 2022
WAS THE YEAR WHEN EUROPE FOUND
ITS UNITY ON CORE VALUES, CORE
PRINCIPLES, IN COURT ACTIONS.
THE WEEKEND AT THE 24TH OF
FEBRUARY INVASION, IT WAS A
THURSDAY, THE WEEKEND AFTER,
THE EUROPEAN UNION CAME
TOGETHER AND MADE STARTLING
PLEDGES, REALLY, THREE YEARS
COMMITMENT TO EVERY REFUGEE
BEING HOUSED, HAVING ACCESS TO
WORK, IT'S GOING TO SCHOOL, AND
ALSO ON THE MILITARY SIDE, A
VERY STRONG EUROPEAN RESPONSE.
THE THREAT IS SO CLEAR, ARE SO
SINGULAR, THAT ACTUALLY AROUND
THE UKRAINE ISSUE, THERE'S A
LOT OF UNITY.
I THINK THE DANGER FOR EUROPE
IS THAT THIS UNITY FINDS ITS
PLACE AND OTHER AREAS.
I THINK 2022 WAS A YEAR OF
STRONGER EUROPEAN UNITY, RATHER
THAN DISUNITY.
>> THE WORLD'S ATTENTION AND
EYES ARE ON UKRAINE RIGHT.
NOW BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO WHAT
IS UNFORTUNATELY A FAIRLY GRIM
LIST THAT IRC IS PUT OUT, IF
YOU ARE AT THE TABLE RIGHT, NOW
WHAT WOULD YOU BE TELLING
LEADERS ABOUT HOW TO GET RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE TO MORE OF A POINT
TO NEGOTIATION?
RIGHT NOW, WE SEEM SO FAR FROM
THAT.
>> WELL I THINK THAT THE FIRST
POINT IS THAT THESE ARE NOT
PARTIES THAT ARE EQUIVALENCE.
ONE PARTY HAS INVADED ANOTHER
COUNTRY INCOMPLETES
COMPREHENSION OF INTERNATIONAL
LAW.
I OBVIOUSLY LEAD A HUMANITARIAN
ORGANIZATION.
I'M AFRAID THAT THE CORE FRONT
IS ON THE MILITARY SIDE, AND
THERE IS A LOT TO PLAY THROUGH
STILL.
I THINK TEN MONTHS INTO THE WAR,
IT'S VERY HARD TO SEE THE
RUSSIANS WINNING.
THAT'S NOT THE SAME AS SAYING
THAT THERE IS A QUICK ROUTE TO
A DEFEATS, AND TO THEIR FOR
SOME KIND OF SETTLEMENTS.
I THINK THE THIS IS HELD UP IN
AN EXTRAORDINARY FASHION.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE IS
A QUICK AND.
THE DECISION-MAKING STRUCTURE,
IN MOSCOW, DOESN'T GIVE THAT TO
PUBLIC OPINION.
IT DOESN'T ALLOW THE MOTHERS OF
THE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WHO HAVE
BEEN KILLED ON THE BATTLEFIELD
TO BE, TO HAVE THEIR VOICES
HEARD.
AND SO YOU'VE GOT THE
SINGULARITY OF DECISION-MAKING
INSIDE THE KREMLIN.
THIS IS REALLY AS THE ONLY
DECISION-MAKER IN THIS.
THIS IS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TERMS ON WHICH RUSSIA IS COMING
TO TERMS WITH THE FAILURE OF
ITS INVASION.
>> LIKELY, UNFORTUNATELY, A
GRIM BUT REALISTIC ASSESSMENT
YOU'VE GIVEN THEIR.
I DO WANT TO MOVE TO THE IRC,
LISTEN IT MAKES FOR GRIM
READING.
I KNOW THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT
OUT OF, THIS YOU WANT ACTION,
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO BE HOPEFUL.
YET, HOW MUCH DO YOU HAVE TO
GUARD AGAINST DONOR FATIGUE
HERE?
I KNOW, A LOT OF THE COUNTRIES
WE SEE ON THE LIST THIS YEAR
WERE ON THE LIST IN PRIOR YEARS,
AND QUITE FRANKLY, FOR DECADES.
>> WELL LET'S EXPLAIN TO YOUR
VIEWERS, THIS UNIQUE WATCHLIST
IS AN EMERGENCY WATCHLISTS,
DRAWN FROM 67 DIFFERENT DATA
SOURCES.
THERE'S A REAL EVIDENCE BASIS
FOR THE PREDICTION OF WHICH
COUNTRY WILL SUFFER GREATEST
HUMANITARIAN NEED IN 2023.
20 COUNTRIES ONLY ON THE
WATCHLIST.
THESE 20 COUNTRIES ACCOUNT FOR
90% OF THE GLOBAL HUMANITARIAN
--
TOTAL, THE U.N. SAID MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE ARE IN HUMANITARIAN
EAT.
90% OF THEM LIVE IN JUST THESE
20 COUNTRIES.
THE CORE DRIVERS OF
HUMANITARIAN NEED OUR CONFLICT,
UKRAINE BEING A PRIME EXAMPLE.
THE CLIMATE CRISIS, AND THEN
THE ECONOMIC SHOCK WAVE,
INCLUDING FROM UKRAINE, BUT
ALSO POST COVID.
YOU RIGHTLY REFER TO THE DANGER
OF JONAH FATIGUE.
THERE ARE TWO STORIES HERE THAT
ARE IMPORTANT.
THERE ARE DONORS, NOTABLY, AND
EUROPE.
THEY ARE NOT STEPPING UP TO THE
GLOBAL NEEDS.
THEY'RE FOCUSED ON UKRAINE.
THE GULF HAS DONE VERY WELL OUT
OF THE RISE AND ENERGY PRICES.
THEY'RE NOT STEPPING UP.
I DO HAVE TO CALL OUT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, THAT'S THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE STORY.
U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS MADE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN 2022,
IN RECOGNIZING THE GLOBAL
CONSEQUENCES OF THE UKRAINE
WAR.
IT'S FOR THAT REASON THAT THEY
HAVE BOOSTED THEIR
INTERNATIONAL, EIGHT ESPECIALLY
FOR EAST AFRICA, WHERE FOOD
PRICES HAVE GROWN SO
SIGNIFICANTLY, HAS A RESULT OF
UKRAINE WAR, AND THE BLOCKAGE
ON RAIN EXPORTS.
A COUNTRY LIKE SOMALIA, WHICH
IS TOP OF OUR, LESS 90% OF ITS
WHEAT COMES FROM UKRAINE.
YOU CAN SEE THE DANGER.
ACROSS FROM TORRENTIAL IS ON
THE WATCH, LESS THERE'S A 40%
RISE IN FOOD PRICE INFLATION.
THIS IS IN LARGE PARTS OF THE
RAIN CONFLICT.
THERE IS GLOBAL CONSEQUENCES
ARE BEING RECOGNIZED BUT THE
U.S..
THEY'RE NOT BEING RECOGNIZED BY
OTHER DONORS.
THE PURPOSE OF OUR WATCHLIST IS
NOT JUST US ON THE WARNING, IT
IS TO BE THE CALL TO ACTION
THAT YOU REFER TO.
WE THINK THERE ARE THINGS THAT
CAN BE DONE.
WE ARE CALLING ON GLOBAL
COMMUNITY TO FOLLOW WHETHER THE
U.S. HAS LED.
>> SOMALIA IS A GOOD CASE IN
POINT.
NO MATTER THE AMERICAN
INVOLVEMENT, AND I TAKE IT THAT
AMERICA IS PERHAPS REENGAGE
THERE.
THEY HAVE BEEN ENGAGED, ON AN,
OFF FOR THREE DECADES.
THE SITUATION IN SOMALIA
CONTINUES TO BE REALLY
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
PEOPLE THERE, AND THE STABILITY
OF THE WHOLE REGION.
WHAT'S CHANGED, AND WHAT CAN
CHANGE IN 2023?
EVEN IF DONOR STEP UP.
>> THAT'S A VERY POWERFUL
POINT.
I QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE
ASKING IT JUST.
FOR BACKGROUND, 15 OF THE 20
COUNTRIES ON THE INTERNATIONAL
RESCUE COMMITTEE'S EMERGENCY --
HAVE BEEN THERE FOR AT LEAST
FIVE YEARS.
YOU'RE MAKING AN IMPORTANT
POINT BUT PROTRACTED CONFLICT.
IN THE CASES SOMALIA, IT HAS A
NEW FACTOR ON THE SCENE, WHICH
IS THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD THE KIND OF
DROUGHT EFFECT THAT IS HITTING
SOMALIA NOW, WE WEREN'T SEEING
THAT 30 YEARS AGO.
I WAS AN EASTERN ETHIOPIA
TOWARDS THE BORDER WITH SOMALIA
JUST LAST MONTH.
YOU CAN SEE THE CONSEQUENCES
ACROSS THE EAST AFRICA REGION
OF SUCCESSIVE MISSED RAINFALLS.
THAT'S A NEW FACTOR IN THE
EQUATION.
IT CALLS FOR STRENGTHENING OF
THE GUARD RAILS AGAINST
DISASTER.
NOW THOSE GUARDRAILS IN THE
FORM OF CLIMATE RESILIENT
AGRICULTURE, AND A FORM OF
INTERNATIONAL AID THAT CAN HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE BRINK OF
FAMINE.
THEN THERE ARE THE DEEPER, MORE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS OF
GOVERNANCE, WHICH I THINK YOU
MIGHT BE REFERRING TO.
GOVERNMENTS IN CONFLICT.
THAT, INDEED, IS A VERY LONG
TERM PROBLEM.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE PLACES
THAT THE IRC WORKS IS THAT THE
TOOLS OF DIPLOMACY TO REGULATE
RELATIONS BETWEEN NATIONS ARE
NOT ADEQUATE FOR OUR CONFLICT
WITHIN NATIONS.
THAT'S WHERE OUR GREATEST
CONCERN.
IS HAITI PRESENTS THE
HUMANITARIAN NEEDS AND OUR
WATCHLIST ARE AFFECTED BY CIVIL
WAR.
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED DIPLOMACY,
TO GET UPSTREAM INSULT SOME OF
THESE PROBLEMS.
>> YEAH, AS YOU PROVOCATIVELY
POINT OUT, WE ARE HAVING
TROUBLE GOVERNING OUR OWN
NATIONS AND VARIOUS STRONG AND
LONG-STANDING DEMOCRACIES.
A AS YOU SAID PROVOCATIVELY,
YOU HAVE POINTED OUT A FRAMING
OF DEMOCRACY VERSUS THE TOP
RUSSI, THIS DOES NOT SPEAK TO
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS IN A WAY
THAT IS OPTIMAL.
PLEASE EXPLAIN THAT IN TERMS OF
WHAT THAT MEANS.
NOR DOES IT SPOKE FOR THE
CONCERNS OUTSIDE OF THE WEST,
IN THE MISTAKES OF DEMOCRATIC
COUNTRIES.
THE ISSUE HERE IS, EVERYTHING
YOU'VE SIGNPOSTED FROM IRC, HOW
DO YOU GET FROM, YOU KNOW, THE
DATA THAT YOU'VE PROVIDED TO
ACTION, WHEN EVEN AS YOU
RIGHTLY POINT, OUT WE ARE IN
CRISIS HERE, OF GOVERNANCE NOT
JUST NATIONALLY, BUT
INTERNATIONALLY.
>> YES, THERE IS A FIGHT FOR
THE RENEWAL AND SUSTENANCE OF
DEMOCRACY.
LESS THAN 20% OF THE GLOBAL
POPULATION LIVE IN A --
CALL A FULLY FREE AND
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM.
THERE IS DEMOCRATIC RECESSION.
THE TROUBLE IS, THE FRAMING OF
DEMOCRACY VERSUS AUTOCRACIES IS
REALLY FOR WITHIN NATIONS
STATES, IT'S NOT A GLOBAL
FREEMAN.
WHAT I ARGUE IS THAT THE GLOBAL
ISSUE IS ONE OF IMPUNITY VERSUS
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND UNITY IS THE EXERCISE OF
POWER WITHOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
AS YOU KNOW, POWER CORRUPTS,
AND ABSOLUTE POWER CORRUPTS
ABSOLUTELY.
ON THE ONE, HAND YOU HAVE THE
RISE OF IMPUNITY, ON THE OTHER
HAND TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY
CHECKS ON THE ABUSE OF POWER.
THAT STARTS THE TRANSPARENCY,
IF ALL AS LEGAL SYSTEMS, IT
INVOLVES COUNTERVAILING PALLOR.
I THINK AS WE THINK ABOUT
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS IN THE
2020 TWENTIES, WE SHOULDN'T BE
THINKING ABOUT IT AS DEMOCRACY
VERSUS AUTOCRACY IN THE
INTERNATIONAL REALM.
WE SHOULD BE THINKING OF IT AS
IMPUNITY VERSUS THE RULE OF
LAW.
THAT IS WHY THE UKRAINE CRISIS
IS SO SIGNIFICANT.
THAT'S WHAT THE DENIAL OF EIGHT,
IMPOSSIBLY --
OR SOMALIA SO SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S THE RULE OF LAW THAT WE
HAVE TO DEFENSE, AND
INTERNATIONAL.
LEVEL WE DON'T WANT NEW LAW, AS
THEY WERE WRITTEN IN THE U.N.
CHARTER, AN ASSOCIATED DOCUMENT,
75 YEARS AGO.
THEY NEED TO BE DEFENDED.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK, THAT'S THE
BASIC FRAMING THAT I THINK CAN
HELP THE INTERNATIONAL LEVEL.